and participating in a clinical trial, what do I think about participating in clinical trials?
I don't think participating in clinical trials is wrong at all. I think it's wrong if you don't
for you, certainly would be wrong. You are doing everything you can naturally. But when you hear
a person that's, you know, getting a very grave diagnosis, they've never even explored any natural
things. And let's say it's a diagnosis that chemotherapy doesn't work well on. Let's say they have
a cancer with a very low success rate with chemotherapy with other standards of care. And they're
offered a clinical trial and they consider it immediately without trying natural things. I think
that's kind of foolish. But if you're exhausting everything and you're doing everything in there,
have some promise in a clinical trial that you feel like God is leading you, that that might be
an answer by all means. I think you could pray about it. But if you feel like God has opened
in your door or something, I think there's anything wrong with to call it walk you down that path.